à mes phrases de david
ce geste cela fait 38 ans que nadine le
répète chaque jour mais se faire servir
une mousse au comptoir du café de la
place ne sera peut-être bientôt plus
possible pourrait bien trouver quelqu'un
on soit acheté les murs et fonds ou
alors un gérant s'il ya des jeunes qui
veulent s'installer en gérance il ya
tout ce qu'il faut il ya l'appartement
il ya là il ya tout ce qu'il faut à la
son compagnon françois n'a qu'une hâte
prendre une retraite bien méritée mais
si le couple cherche un repreneur depuis
bientôt trois ans difficile de trouver
un candidat parce qu'il n'embauchait
pour les jeunes mais ce qui me
connaissent moi il m'appelle nos fins
c'est pour ça que il venir
roger waite
dès 8 heures du matin les habitués
viennent ici déguster un petit noir
alors impossible pour eux d'imaginer
leur village au son café ça sera ma
l'europe ce que son bar du village belle
vie là j'y serai mort je pense que si on
n'a pas le baril si ça serait crise déjà
que le village est pas forcément très
animé c'est un lieu de rencontre et on
va chercher le pain on passe ici ou
n'importe quoi que ces
moyens de retrouver des copains ou
n'importe quoi est discuté en impôts
ensemble et puis voilà des cafés le
village de neuvy pailloux et ses 1200
habitants en compter jusqu'à
400 repreneur le dernier café du village
pourrait tirer le rideau à la fin de
l'année